a rescue on the outskirts of sydney this
family believed they could handle the
flood
but the water rose so fast before they
knew it the only way out was by boat
waking up at about 2am and seeing water
creeping up to the house it was
it was difficult sleeping but uh yeah no
it's it's definitely scary especially
with kids
already this year there's been multiple
floods in new south wales
and people are tired of it flood fatigue
there is covered for tea this flood
fatigue get the woman with me
that's what i'm feeling the the two
words to describe it it's just
i'm just tired of the floods more than
30 000 people have been evacuated from
homes in and around sydney or have been
warned to get ready for it
as yet again australia's east coast is
battered by rain
a month's worth of it in only two days
it's incredible uh in the last
18 months we've had three major flood
events in this area and we're talking
about water depths getting way above
head level
in some areas and you know multiple
people having to be evacuated animals
needing to be rescued and also people as
well
wild weather saw a cargo ship stuck
without power
and drifting towards rocky sea cliffs
a helicopter rescue had to be aborted
eventually it was towed away from danger
this major bridge on the outskirts of
sydney has been lost under a mile wide
river and with the flood waters still
rising people are bracing themselves for
even more homes to go under
so they're getting ready
moving whatever they can to higher
ground or a shipping container
this is an area prone to flooding but
not this often
keith levy moved in here six months ago
since then
four floods
the ground floor is under a meter of
muddy water
he's given up bothering to pump it out
is this climate change
i think partially i think there's a lot
of factors i think dam management as
well is um a
cause of what's also going on and also
the human footprint we're putting on
the area as well
with barely time to recover from one
flood the region is hit with another
it's been called sydney's new normal
but nothing feels normal about this
nicole johnston sky news
sydney